whoo Wow I didn't know you could do that
it's 8:00 in the morning and the new
episode of Oscars Hotel just came out me
and Mark said did voice acting for it
and we never heard how it sounded like
so I'm really excited to watch it so
weird but it was really awesome you bros
to check out the episode I'll leave a
link to it in the description what do
you think might say yeah can we get much
higher
keep it up breasts I love that you love
the blogs some arts say what do you
think of legend of the brofist all right
we're going to Santa Monica I love that
place my favorite place in LA okay
Santa Monica let's go we're here yes
it's been so long Myanmar's actually
lived nearby here and this was our
favorite place the memories are coming
back
Oh somewhere somewhere popular place
okay
it's really good further I remember this
that's some good food man I like that we
both put up the cameras at the same time
getting out things later on guys come on
I think I won no that was fun
whoa what the hell how is it every time
we go out we end up going shopping okay
we're going to the beach now don't you
worry clearly me after I go drinking
this Beach let's Brighton Beach look
like an ant you figured like people want
to look so much just kissing hugging but
people still stare hurt a lot Hey
the smog is very thick today I see you
guys too many people okay another good
view
holy crap okay okay are they upstairs
someone
no jamming out on the pool where are we
going on that eggs okay hold on really
hard okay that's my roller coaster no
more we are going through the creepy
tunnel I hope we will make it through
I wanted to swim really bad but the
water smells kind of weird here I smell
weird we're gonna walk a little awkward
I smell weird thank you so much I think
this is a bad idea I'm gonna come back
there was a bunch of condoms yeah
this speech is disgusting and I'm not
going in with my head are you being
Baywatch my gamer muscles
whoo Wow
that's what I have to kill while you're
not here what is that
I've never seen one that big
I don't like la anymore oh I dropped it
I'm shooting today at 7 p.m. so I have
two hours to chill it's 7 p.m. my day
starts now
I don't belong a lot while I'm away for
the shoots because I can't but so much
happen it's not fair I can't wait for
your us to see you what I'm doing here
I can't wait this is how much look at
this I need to stop kissing the lens cuz
there you go nice and clean no more band
stuff we're going to nut cane yeah hey
what is he doing here no one knows it's
the do you have a theory it's a secret
alright we just wrapped up another of
the secret stuff that we're doing really
enjoy this one I think this one is my
favorite so much fun I'm loving doing
this got to meet Matt for the first time
awesome dude really hope I can meet him
again got to meet another youtuber not
gonna say who it is cuz I didn't film
him so I might as well keep it secret
today was amazing
alright might yeah and him has gay you
vlogging me money you'd say I'm gonna
enter CMRR brush stairs this first piece
entitled granny gun post
it feels so nice I've got to look so
good no don't stop